welcome to the heavy spoilers reaction
shadow hey we're going to watch some
heavy spoilers paul you sexy sob hot
daddy you spiderman away home deleted
scenes if you guys haven't subscribed to
heavy spoilers yet do it recently put
out this amazing easter egg video
featuring yours truly and then like a
bunch of nobodies cause of wonder new
rock stars supes
those guys even matter emergency awesome
grace randolph moore
so many people he knows i thought i was
the only other youtuber you were friends
whatever man anyway let's check this out
[Music]
okay so the first major one that we know
about featured matt murdock and foggy
now sorry
happy in the film we get a brief scene
in which matt tells peter that the
charges won't stick but he then says
happy is going to have to layer up
because the feds are still coming for
him john farrow of course played foggy
nelson in the daredevil movie opposite
ben affleck and the deleted scene was
going to take more of a focus on him and
matt murdock titled happy's very good
lawyer
focused on the pair discussing his
apparent illegal acquisition of stock
tech and how it helped to fund peter's
terrorist acts yes he did it the
murderer got away with it hashtag
mysterio was right mysterio was right
stop we don't know that's all though we
don't have the full ins and outs of this
scene it is theorized that there's
someone opposite the pair and that this
could be foggy himself played once more
by eldon henson daredevil itself is now
just moved
and with kingpin showing up in hawkeye
it does make sense that he would pop up
too though we're gonna have to wait
until the full scene's released to know
for sure it's also been confirmed that
morgan stark would have made an
appearance during the scene which goes
over the star stock tech lexi rape was
supposed to return us the character and
we would have got flashes of her during
the montage in these moments in addition
to this we were also going to get more
focus on the interrogation scene with
damage control which would flesh out
peter's interaction with them it would
also showcase him seeking legal help and
some of the questioning that was put
towards ned mj and also may the main
reason why i would have wanted to see
that scene is if the foggy from the
daredevil show was in that scene itself
as well it would be just so cool on that
metal level to watch foggy from the ben
affleck movie interact with foggy from
the modern day mcu and i think it would
have worked in the sense of like how
they're going around the interrogations
with everyone like ned mj seeing the
consequences of what it's like to be
associated with peter parker that weight
of consequences being placed on foggy
himself in the movie would have been
cool but if they're gonna bring up all
this legal talk and whatnot regarding
his involvement in association feel like
the rest of the movie might not have
been flushed out enough to resolve that
storyline and as it stands i think the
daredevil entrance with the kane coming
into frame just makes for the baller
entrance so you couldn't just have that
be the second scene it just would have
worked as well yeah then you would want
a third scene and more distractions like
the daredevil versus coming back and all
that stuff yeah now we do have a big
list of deleted scenes and it seems like
wow
around things early on in the movie this
includes a lot of montage graduation day
an extended doctor strange entrance and
a couple more daily vehicle reports
i forgot to mention in our every easter
egg video that when peter enters midtown
high it's meant to parallel his entrance
to the school in homecoming the movie
had him basically being a complete
unknown as he walks through the crowd
whereas no way home has everyone staring
at him completely filming the character
on their phones and then head over to
youtube to like comment and subscribe
the best channel out there
now these reports basically had people
ringing in and talking to jaytona
jameson about how spider-man saved the
day at several points in the movie one
was in the aftermath of the fight with
electro that basically talked about how
he stayed there all night helping to fix
the power lines interesting
you're saying you saw spider-man with
your own eyes destroying multiple power
lines well technically he did destroy
those power lines
well there you have it folks first hand
run unimpeachable
wait i wasn't finished
i'm sorry spiderman was stopping this
guy who was absorbing all the energy
from the lines
spider-man stopped that dude and then he
spent the whole night repairing the
damage i saw it interesting voice for
something that's amazing
we'll have to uh circle back and confirm
this folks
we'll be right back after a brief word
from daily bugle supplements
the only other daily fix you need and
we're out okay which one of you former
employees vetted that nut job
now i like that scene in isolation i
think just releasing it as a deleted
scene works a little bit better because
i prefer the movie where he's having to
work so hard to make repairs and if they
had that scene in there it would start
making it feel like the public is coming
back around a spidey a little too early
on in the movie that scene at the very
end when he does call into the daily
bugle it still feels like the world is
against him right now and then at that
moment it probably would have relieved
some of that tension of like no there's
a lot of public support for him actually
yeah and i feel like too you would need
to make that a more tangible through
line throughout the movie cutting more
frequently to actual like callers into
the daily bugle and make that more of a
you know actual piece rather than you
know what it is in the current movie
structurally speaking yeah but as it
stands as a scene alone i think it's a
fun scene i'm glad it exists there's
also a bit on the flash's book
flashpoint available in all good
bookshops now he and i have been best
friends for years i mean this is this is
a school that we wrote together for
years i mean he's constantly following
me up those steps and you know we get
into trouble we do what we can you know
as if our public schools weren't
dangerous enough between the lead paint
asbestos and salisbury steak made from
military horses
don't believe me check out my four-part
expose on dailybugle.net actually i
would have liked that
beyond this we also got a couple of
seconds released in which the villains
peter and may all stand in an elevator
together as they head to happy's
apartment it's a pretty good shot of the
full cast on screen together at the same
time that i quite like because it's nice
just seeing them having this monday
moment before it all kicks off yeah
later on so she can't go to the elevator
doc ock salmon and electro go the window
and peter and goblin crash through
several floors on their way out this
moment in the elevator was meant to
juxtapose that and show them going up in
a really sensible normal way before all
hell breaks loose apparently this was
cut because the director wanted to keep
up the pace of the film and have us go
from the sanctorum directly to the
apartment we just had the murder mention
chase so john watts wanted to keep
everything at a high level but i would
have actually liked to have seen this
play out yeah you see like that is a
conflict because you gotta factor in
pacing and the structure of how your
your movie's flowing but to get the shot
of like all of them excluding you know
toby and andrew but to get the shot of
all of them in the in the same frame
would have just been so cool to look at
there's a neat flavor about that as much
as it's like a like you said classic
joke of the awkward weight going up the
elevator amidst the tension phil moment
still would have been cool you can just
hear the audience like both trying to
clap and laugh at the same thing
like this yeah i just like how norman
looks so enamored by whoa that's what
elevator floor buttons look like
we don't have those on our
time for a joke what's spider-man's
favorite day blind day
what's spider-man's favorite month web
you are e
what's the opposite of happy hogan sad
hogan because
dead anyway speaking of february we now
have our competition winners for the
last month on screen right now so if
that's you then get in touch with me at
twitter at heavyspoilers now we also
know from the concept art and interviews
with the creative team that mysterio was
to tell us to return in the movie
come the end of the film we watch as the
multiverse is cracked open and several
characters come across that now peter
parker is spider-man during the shot in
which we get craven the hunter and
scorpion you can also catch the
distinctive fishbowl head of the master
of illusions and the creative team
confirmed it was indeed supposed to be
him mysterio of course exposed peter's
identity to the world and thus it does
make sense that he was gonna be the
villain that showed up concept up for
the movie has since been released and it
shows mysterio was supposed to duke it
out with doctor strange at the statue of
liberty if we look at his powers or
rather illusions and far from home they
were actually based around strange's
magic and it would have been great to
see them face off against each other
even though mysterio is faker than iggy
azalea's accent
i don't know if this has been confirmed
or not you guys can let me know down
below i've heard at least i think it
might just be speculation it was
supposed to be mysterio from another
dimension
and that mysterio actually had actually
powers that would make a lot more sense
yeah i'm like what is he going to do
against doctor strange
he could just wipe away the illusions
or something i'm just going to throw my
cloak of levitation yeah and we're done
we don't need to fight anymore but i
gotta say like it would have been a real
delight because mysterio is such a
classic spider-man villain and jake
gyllenhaal was great playing him as well
it would have been a really great treat
the creative team actually discussed
this in more detail and they went over
his appearance would have worked
speaking at ign fan fest 2022 they said
how opening up the multiverse at the end
meant opening up infinite possibilities
on who could come through they really
wanted mysterio back but they realized
that if they brought in one character
they'd have to bring it more you
couldn't just have one from the
multiverse break through at the end so
they'd need to at least have a handful
for it not to feel disappointing but
then it would feel slightly overwhelming
that's true that's a good point in the
main battle you need another action
simple with a focus on the five villains
that's a great point
that's a good point
was supposed to appear and that she was
going to be the one that brought toby
and andrew across we have a scene at the
dudgeons where she's standing in the
middle with several characters around
here and america can also be seen at the
statue of liberty battle i've already
done a full video on this so i don't
want to go about old ground but yeah
we're talking about that
role in the film now if you cast your
mind back to the build-up of the movie
then you might remember that tom
holland's brother harry was supposed to
be in a scene but this too got cut and
if he was a thief that robbed the store
and then peter caught him and strung him
up it was at this point that the green
paint was thrown over peter and he ended
up having to turn his suit inside out
for the fight with electro now we also
know that toby maguire was supposed to
fight with the green goblin on his
glider
that was somewhat reminiscent of the
playstation 2
oh man
all that much yeah no they could in a
future film with him ending up alive i
did want to see them at least have a toe
to toe at some point the deleted scene
hurts more than finding out that you
only got one thousand dollars even
though the ad said three thousand
spider-man fought sandman and the
amazing spider-man for the lizard but
the face-off with the foe was sadly
missing their rivalry was one of the
most memorable things about the original
spider-man film and i kind of hope that
we at least get them on screen together
again at some point yeah like the fact
that they didn't interact at all when
this all began with the two of them this
began with toby and uh norman awesome
uh and i i wish that we got something
like that if any i really just craved a
dialogue exchange between them towards
the end the way that they gave one to
him and otto i wanted one with him and
him and uh normie we didn't even get
that would that would have been cool to
see because i don't
do we get that in the original
spider-man movie where they're fighting
directly on the glider i don't think we
did not directly on and i don't think
yeah he uses it against him a number of
times but it would be so cool to see him
actually trying to keep control of it
while you know duking it out crawling
around it too
anyway that's all the deleted scenes
info that we have released over the last
couple of days and i hope you enjoyed
the video obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on whether you think
things should have been cut or not so
comment below and let me know great
video paul fantastic video dude it still
boggles my mind that they're messed up
some of the shots are best for cgi it's
like why there's so much the visual
effects i don't understand that i'm like
when i make a practical i get mad at
first i'm sure they had good reasoning
go on a real scaffolding i'm sure
there's a reason why they had cgi yeah
but guys thank you so much for watching
uh leave a like follow heavy spoilers
check out his awesome easter egg
breakdown he i i know for a fact he
worked tirelessly on it many many many
many hours and a lot of manpower went
into that video so please go check that
out i'll link it in the pink comment
yeah let's do it
spencer it's nice to have you back the
multiversal void ripped open and what
did we get we got our lovely spencer
back in our safe hands and arms we're
here and we love to have you i hope that
you have had a good year thus far i hope
that you're excited for the home video
release of spider-man if we could all do
a watch party together i would love that
we could cuddle put my arms around you i
could whisper things in your ear do like
a little commentary just for you spencer
make it real nice and awkward for you so
that you don't even want to come back
next month that's what i'm all about man
i'm all about closeness and intimacy and
spider-man so hey hope you're doing well
hope you enjoyed this video hope you
enjoyed spider-man no way home and
weren't cripplingly disappointed by the
fact that norman osborne and toby
mcguire didn't get to interact that much
hey we're interacting right now and
that's what counts so be well take care
and we'll see you next month much love
buddy
[Music]